welcome back so in the last video we
talked a lot about how you can use
modern methods in data science and
machine learning to tackle really hard
control systems of modern interest where
you might have unknown dynamics
nonlinear systems very high dimensional
States and limited measurements and in
particular we talked about how you could
get into data driven modeling you could
characterize your system with data you
can do data driven control you can
directly use machine learning to learn
effective control laws and we can also
use these methods for optimization for
sparse optimal sensor and actuator
placement so right now what I'm going to
talk about is essentially an overview of
data driven modeling okay so now I'm
gonna give you just the roadmap of how
you would use data science and machine
learning for system identification so
really that's what I'm talking about is
system identification and this will be a
large part of this lecture series so
there will be multiple lectures in the
vein of system identification right now
all I'm doing is giving you a big
roadmap of what to expect what you're
gonna find so system identification is
an old subject this has been around at
least since ho and calman in the mid 60s
and it's had a really rich history in
control theory and dynamical systems
ever since then so in the 80s there was
the eigen system realization algorithm
that was very useful for characterizing
flexible space structures aerospace
structures like the Hubble and the
International Space Station where it was
hard to get a first principles model of
the of the dynamics because you had this
very complicated kind of elastic
structure and they used system
identification to learn a linear model
of the dynamics directly from
measurement data okay so so system
identification and this data-driven
modeling is not new this is not
something that was invented with machine
learning in the last 10 years this has
been around for half a century okay
and I again I'm a big umbrella machine
learning person I think of system
identification as
a form of machine learning what you're
doing is you're learning models that
generalize based on past data so I
collect data from a system I build a
model and I hope that that model
generally generalizes to to the future
to new input measurements you that I
haven't seen before and oftentimes if
you get the physics right if you
constrain that optimization in the right
way or you train it on a rich enough
data set this really does give you
models that generalize to be useful in
in practice in the field and so I think
of system identification as being a form
of old machine learning for dynamical
systems okay again this is just a road
map of what to expect in this kind of
part on system ID so part one is really
system identification sometimes I'm
gonna talk about something called model
reduction okay and these are very
similar and related things but let me
just give you the very high-level
difference okay so system identification
is where I collect data I measure X in
time and I measure maybe u in time I
kick the system and I measure what
happens and I build a proxy model for F
for the dynamics that's system
identification I identify a system what
model reduction does this is very
interesting sometimes I actually have a
model of my system I know the navier's
stokes equation for turbulence okay so I
have this ridiculously big hairy
equation maybe I take my PDE my partial
differential equation for Navy or Stokes
i discretize it on a million grid cells
in a simulation and I get a million
dimensional nonlinear ordinary
differential equation people do this all
the time and computational fluid
dynamics so I might actually have a
model but I don't want a million
dimensional model I want a model that
only describes the dominant most
important things that happen for a
particular configuration so maybe I have
an airfoil and that airfoil is
undergoing vortex shedding so even
though I would need to represent this in
a simulation with a million or a billion
degrees of freedom I might be able to
find a reduced order model a model that
captures most
of the interesting dynamics maybe in
terms of five or ten or 50 states
instead of a million okay if I if I find
a good coordinate system that's what all
the physics is about is finding a good
coordinate system I might be able to
represent these dynamics in a reduced
order representation so that's what
model reduction is I have a big hairy
model but I want to find a more
tractable simpler model maybe in terms
of a dot a state a which is much smaller
than X which is equal to some F of a so
a much much smaller model that captures
most of the dynamics that's what model
reduction is and what we're gonna find
is that a lot of the same techniques can
be used both for model reduction if I
have the model and I want to reduce it
or if I have no model and I just have
data and I wanted to discover a model
okay now again there's lots and lots of
different layers of system
identification for anything that's a
half a century old I'm only going to be
able to give you kind of that the
shallow treatment okay so read more
about this there's a rich rich history
of system identification I'm only gonna
tell you the highlights so a huge part
of this is based around linear system
identification now you might be asking
yourself why linear system
identification well the most powerful
techniques in control theory are
developed for linear dynamical systems
so if I had X dot equals ax and a is a
matrix so X is a vector a is a matrix
plus B you there are known close form
optimal control laws to stabilize and
regulate these systems if I know a and B
so a lot of system identification goes
into learning a and B from measurement
data okay that's that's probably the
bulk of that half a century from this
you know sixties until recently most of
that went into linear system
identification and again one of the
things of interest here is oftentimes my
system state might be very very high
dimensional so what I would want to do
is also learn a good coordinate system I
would also want to learn a good
coordinate system so that I
much smaller model I'm going to write it
in terms of this little a state let's
call it a dot equals a tilde of a plus B
tilde of U so I still have a control
knob you but I only want to affect the
these this small vector a that
represents most of the structures I'm
going to see in this high dimensional
data X and we'll talk about this this is
going to be a little vague at this point
but basically I want to learn the
dynamics and I want to learn a good
coordinate system I want to learn a good
representation of X so that I don't need
a million degrees of freedom maybe I can
get away with five degrees of freedom
okay now some of these these methods
include the eigen system realization
algorithm we're going to talk a lot
about that that's a system
identification technique that was
developed in I think 1985 we're gonna
talk a lot about balanced truncation BT
and balanced proper orthogonal
decomposition so these are both
techniques for model reduction if I have
a model of a linear system but it's
really high dimensional and I want to
find just the few coordinates that
matter we're gonna look at balance
truncation and balance P OD
we're also going to look at a more
recent technique called dynamic mode
decomposition d-md dynamic mode
decomposition this is more recent kind
of 2008 until present people are still
developing this this DM D algorithm
these are all methods that we're going
to discuss and what the basic idea is
we're going to collect data and we're
going to learn representations of a and
B and we're also going to learn good
coordinate systems so that we can reduce
this model into a more tractable form
okay why might I want a five dimensional
model instead of a million dimensional
model well lots of reasons if I'm going
to develop a control law I'm actually
going to have to base my controller on
some state of my system X or a and if
I'm going to be flying this around in a
drone using an iPhone you know as the
computer I'd rather be simulating a five
dimensional Oh de for my control
prediction than a million dimensional
so this gives me faster model
predictions and faster model predictions
gives me faster control and faster
control means lower latencies and higher
bandwidth so from the control bootcamp
you should know in your heart now if I
have time delays if I have a slow
prediction step to get my eight my
controller that's going to introduce a
time delay in my system from here to
here and it's going to cause my system
to have instability or it'll make it so
I can't track fast changes and fast
disturbances so if I want to have fast
tight system response I better have a
really really small minimal reduced
order model so that I can get really
really really fast predictions and and
control decisions okay
so huge amount of work on linear linear
system identification now oftentimes
we'll focus on just learning the
intrinsic the dynamics x equals a of X
and I'll forget about the bu like for
example DMD is based on just learning
this a matrix but extensions like DMD
with control also learn learn this B
matrix okay for very high dimensional
systems so that's something we'll talk
about another interesting fact set here
is nonlinear system identification so
n:l non-linear system ID I'm going to
just use a ton of acronyms mnl system ID
means nonlinear system identification
this is also a very very important
branch of system identification it's not
quite as prevalent as linear system ID
because these models are harder to get
and harder to use for control it's that
simple okay if I had a nonlinear system
and I want to control it it's harder to
control and it's also harder to get a
nonlinear model from data this is just
taken a lot longer to get good at doing
this this is a very very big field and a
lot of great people have done work on
this so there's a lot of work on what
are called norm ax models nonlinear
autoregressive moving average exogenous
input I'm just going to say NAR max
these are some of the oldest and still
some of the best nonlinear modeling
techniques what I'm going to tell you
about now so this is for X dot equals f
of X there's this new method that we've
developed called the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics the
acronym is Cindy okay and basically this
is a new method using sparse
optimization to learn what this f of X
is directly from data and there's a
whole video on this I'll point you to
the the link in the comments you can
learn about kind of modern methods to
learn dynamical systems and the cool
thing about Cindy is you actually learn
the structure of your nonlinear dynamic
so you can write down the OD e and you
can analyze the terms it's interpretable
and physical and it seems to work in a
lot of cases you can learn OD e's PDEs
controlled systems and so on and so
forth there's been some really
interesting work before cindy kind of
after an R max between these two which
is using genetic programming to learn
dynamical systems so this is work by
Bongard and Schmidt and libsyn kind of
in the 2007 to 2009 timeframe really
really nice work using genetic
programming to learn I learned this f of
X so these are all techniques and this
is again just just a few techniques that
I'm naming right now for nonlinear
system identification lots of times you
will have a system that's fundamentally
non-linear there's no good linear
approximation and you have to model what
is X dot equals f of X okay hopefully
everyone's still with me so far this is
just the roadmap now the last thing that
I want to talk about here are models
based on measurements so something I
didn't talk about here I talked a little
bit about it I have dynamics in terms of
the state X but oftentimes I only have
measurements y equals G of X ok so these
measurements Y they could be some linear
measurement they can just measure the
states a few of the states of X or they
could be these nonlinear functions of X
it could be sine of X
one the first component of X or X 2
squared minus X 1 cube that could be a
measurement G of X and there's kind of
infinitely many measurements I could
take of a system okay and so there's
this new emerging field which is kind of
dynamics on measurements and I'm gonna
put a question mark here because it's
not always clear when and how this is
possible so this is related to a new
field it's not a new field actually this
was invented in the 1930s but its newly
Reimer tree emerging because of data
driven modeling called Koopman theory
okay so this is related to something
called Koopman theory and the idea is if
I have enough of these measurements why
maybe I actually have a lot of
measurements in my system and maybe I'm
in the big data limit and I measure more
than enough stuff about my system can I
build a model can I learn a model why
dot equals and I'm gonna call this K of
Y because this is supposed to be
approximating the Koopman operator can I
learn a big dynamical system directly on
the measurements of my system these
nonlinear measurements that I take of my
system ok and if I do that maybe I can
take nonlinear dynamics so what Koopman
Theory says actually is if I have enough
of these measurements if I in the limit
as Y goes to infinity if I have
infinitely many measurements rich enough
measurements on my system even these
nonlinear dynamics can look linear this
is amazing so there's one I like
emphasize this point many systems are
fundamentally nonlinear and need this
description to be able to simulate them
and predict what to do with your control
and then you would do model predictive
control on this even in those systems if
I have enough of a rich enough
measurement set Y it may be possible to
embed these dynamics in a rich
measurement space Y where the dynamics
start to look linear this is very
similar actually to what the support
vector machine and support vector
regression do they take your system and
they embed them in this big measurement
space where things start to look linear
that's what this is doing and whenever I
say linear
you should be thinking easy optimal
control in closed form if I can write a
nonlinear system in a linear
representation we have known optimal
control solutions to handle those
situations okay so this is emerging and
very very promising for doing nonlinear
optimal control using linear theory very
cool linear theory is like textbook
control theory one-line MATLAB commands
so let's just put that in here one-line
MATLAB control now the real trick here
the the kind of modern research is how
do I find a good measurement set why how
do I find good measurements so that this
linear approximation really does work
for nonlinear dynamics that's unknown
and it's emerging this is something
that's still being developed okay all of
these techniques once I build a model so
you know why would I do data driven
modeling data driven modeling is so I
can do model-based control so we could
do linear quadratic regulator if we have
a linear model in lots of cases we're
gonna do model predictive control so I'm
going to put this down model predictive
control this is called MPC very very
important control technique this is lots
of industrial control uses model
predictive control it's super flexible
you can build in constraints it can
handle nonlinear dynamics time delay as
you name it it's awesome and so a lot of
the system identification is building
towards this model predictive control
framework this requires my dynamics to
be fast to simulate I'm going to be
simulating a lot of different
trajectories and testing them out and so
I need these simulations to be fast so
again that goes back to this model
reduction we want even if we have big
high dimensional dynamics I want to find
the minimal form necessary to describe
the dynamics I care about for control
okay so that's going to be a big theme
is high dimensional dynamics to the
intrinsic essential low dimensional
representation in the context of system
identification yeah I think that's about
it so just last thoughts on this
overview
there are a lot of videos out there by
by myself and my colleagues on Cindy so
I'm going to point to those references
we have a lot of videos out there on DMD
so I'm gonna point to those videos a lot
of stuff out there on Koopman the new
videos that I'm going to generate for
this lecture series I'm going to
generate some new videos on balance
truncation and BPO D I'm going to do a
little bit more on kind of the history
and use of DM d and Koopman er a eigen
system realization algorithm really
important when I don't want to forget
neural networks so neural networks are
actually getting really good at
predicting dynamical systems so we're
also going to talk about how to use
neural networks to model nonlinear
dynamical systems very cool so we'll
talk about this as well we'll talk about
model predictive control in a lot of
these cases what we're going to talk
about is how to extend DMD and Cindy and
Koopman to handle this plus bu to handle
control most of these methods DMD Cindy
and Koopman are normally just used to
identify unforced dynamics so we're
going to have to extend them to include
the effect of actuation you now really
really important all of these methods
all of them are fundamentally regression
based so regression is an incredibly
powerful tool all the way back to hoe
and calman they were using essentially
linear regression on data to discover
these models everything we're going to
talk about is regression and so this is
kind of the main technique that we're
thinking about in terms of machine
learning and statistical learning and
there's flavors of regression we could
do sparse regression okay that's what
Cindy is gonna do we're only going to
pick a few model terms to describe F so
that it remains tractable and
interpreted we can have constrained
regressions so I can discover models if
I know that there's constraints or
symmetries we can enforce those in the
regression and there's there's many many
others so this is all going to be about
regression of data onto dynamical
systems that's what system identify
okay so where there's gonna be a ton of
videos on this and then we'll talk about
how to learn controllers and optimal
sensor and actuator placement later okay
thank you